todavía no se conocen cuáles serán las
implicaciones y que sabemos que la
investigación de la fiscalía va a llevar
un tiempo y que este tiempo podría
alargarse mucho más allá del fin del
segundo mandato de sebastián piñera por
lo tanto lo que sigue es un golpe muy
fuerte es a la confianza en un país en
el que las confianza ya están dañadas
este representa un cuerpo por un fuerte
golpe al gobierno de sebastián piñera el
hecho de que al contrario de lo que ya
se había dicho por parte de presidencia
que señalaba que estos hechos ya habían
sido profundamente investigados había
partes de esta investigación que había
partes de estos de estos sucesos que no
se habían incluido en la investigación
inicial como señaló la fiscalía este
viernes cristian que es la concesión
constitucional que la oposición ha
anunciado que presentará contra el
mandatario
la consideración constitucional supone
un mecanismo por parte del congreso de
control en el que sería una especie de
impeachment a la chilena que podría
finalizar de ser positiva y de reunir
los votos algo que todavía no está
seguro por parte de los diputados de la
oposición e inhabilitando la función del
presidente esta sería la segunda vez que
el presidente sebastián piñera se somete
a este proceso aunque la primera no
llegó a prosperar veremos en esta en
este momento muy cercano a las próximas
fechas electorales lo que también podría
tener un impacto en los candidatos que
se presentan del lado del oficialismo
cuál va a ser el resultado si la
oposición llega a congregar todos los
votos necesarios para que esta acusación
se prospere